[Music]
there's a nip in the air it's autumnal
it feels like playoff baseball weather
kyle hendricks here at wrigley he's got
the lowest homie r.a in major league
baseball this year and last combined for
pitchers who have thrown at least 100
innings 2.10 two down minute first and
third top of the first no score so no
with a dozen home runs
hit off the hands on the ground to short
baez will throw to first base in time to
end the inning the twins walk away
empty-handed well hill's only thrown 26
innings so limited batters that he's
seen and that's been an issue for rich
at times his command has not been great
he's walking about four batters per nine
back to back walks
two on nobody out and the batter is
wilson contreras kick and the 1-1
that'll get down in center rizzo is
going to score
and the cubs have the early lead it's
one to nothing
they take advantage of back-to-back
walks contrast gets a fastball up above
the belt real nice swing for contreras
draw first blood one-nothing cubs
second-handing the pitch to polanco
strike three called off-speed pitch got
him third strikeout for hendricks love
to watch him change speeds and mix up
his stuff here's marwyn gonzalez there
goes pitches a strike the throw is on
time
with a nice tag two to six caught
stealing no runs a hit none left he's a
completely different pitcher danny is
his his usage of pitches what he throws
when he throws it not at all what he did
when he was a cub back at 07. and the
2-2 strike three called on a breaking
ball painted down and inside third
strikeout for hill here's schwarber
he just hit schwarber
we'll stay here but i'm not gonna let
him have it oh he's saying he leaned
into it and rossi will not like that
we've had this conversation a number of
times already this year how you never
see this called
the previous there was a previous
curveball in the sequence where kyle
looked like he was willing to lean in or
let it hit him
uh it didn't this time it did his action
this time for me wasn't quite as blatant
but 99.99999
nine percent of the time that's a hit by
pitch yes
called strike three
just thinking if donaldson hits one is
he gonna
put dirt over third base so now and
their shortstop polanco grew up together
in the dominican republic here's the
one-two pitch swing and a missed strike
three
suno chased a low change up cameron
maven picked up eleventh team he's been
with but still he's a good defender 3-2
pitch and a ground ball it's going to be
fueled by donaldson at third cross the
diamond
to retire
cameron mayman three up three down nice
job rich hill
through four it's one nothing chicago
dubs lead one to nothing in the fifth
two down basis empty the 2-2 pitch from
hendricks
strike three called on the inside corner
polanco didn't like it it's a one two
three inning hendricks rolling along
hendrix has sat down 10 in a row switch
hitting marwyn gonzalez
[Music]
got him looking and he is locked in and
steal it three straight strikeouts
for hendricks if you're tired eleven in
a row that's the little come on back to
seymour at 88 miles per hour buxton
swing and a miss on a chain jump
this is toying with these hitters right
now
i mean he's throwing every pitch exactly
where he wants to
hill the crafty veteran
in the pitch he's we're going to miss
got him fastball
as baez strikes out nice job rich hill
gets up one hit strands one
two down here in the seventh mitch
garver waits the one-two pitch swinging
a miss strike three that's ten
chocolato baby now rich hill had his
best start as a twin he went seven
innings one run three hits he walked two
struck out five but right now he is on
the hook as the cubs have a one nothing
lead bottom eight first out of the pen
left-hander caleb thielbarg two down and
here's brian
missed outside with a fastball two-out
walk
and that'll bring up contreras in the
3-0 pitch and that is high ball four
that's a poor pitch walk so back-to-back
two-on-ones
ill demar vargas you remember him and
the 3-2 he got him strike three in a
high fastball that would have been ball
four
so vargas aggressive strikes out
swinging and the cubs do not add up cubs
won twins nothing the run came in the
first inning jeffress has been good all
year this is his 20th appearance picked
up four wins along the way seven saves
and nine tries in a 177 era kepler has
three steals by the way three for three
for the year he's got his lead he's the
tying run at first
now it's three and two
swing and a miss strike three and the
cubs win the ball game
jeremy jeffress strikes out eddie
rosario
and the cubs win the game by the score
of one to nothing